i mean the difference between whether  you're going to be earning x or 2x or 3x  a year  uh 20 years from now uh  is going to be a function of how well  not how much talent you have but how  how well you use the talents you already  have and  so that is the your best financial  future  is your own ability and and and  your uh a capacity to  to use those abilities to their  potential  and they can't take that can't be taken  away from you  they can't even tax it i mean uh you  know most things  if if you wanna you know a piece of real  estate if they double the taxes they  double the taxes and that changes  your ownership in the property because  now in effect the taxing authorities own  more of it because they've got a greater  command on the revenue stream  uh the same thing about almost any asset  you have  but they they don't tax what's in your  head